all right so an obi-wan Kenobi movies
coming out figure I should talk about
that I do want to give you my thoughts I
know I'm not wearing the Star Wars
curtain cape because they're not really
fan going about this moment the trailer
comes out if the trailer is awesome yeah
bring on the curtain kay for now I have
some concerns that has a need to have
some once now I'm going to dress him
here so in a world where a standalone
spin-off Star Wars movie of obi-wan
Kenobi is coming out one of the things I
want to see I already tweeted about this
I want to see you in McGregor back eewan
McGregor as obi-wan Kenobi was one of
the reasons prequel haters were like oh
yeah he's good even when he's like
killing younglings what the [ __ ] is this
sure he went McGregor was good he
brought it he committed and he's the
right age he was McGregor in real life
is about 10 years younger than obi-wan
Kenobi is supposed to be in the original
Star Wars movie which is funny that's me
saying yeah obi-wan Kenobi supposed to
be in his mid-50s he looks about 80
that's what living on a desert planet
will do to you it'll whether you you'll
look older i thought--like want to find
my head anyone at which point you have
to think yourself what how old is ray
really herbs so I want you in McGregor
back another thing I want is I want to
see a movie about a damaged man obi-wan
Kenobi has been through some stuff he is
carrying a lot on his shoulders this is
a man who was a part of a religion that
was an order of monks that were the
keepers of peace and freedom in the Old
Republic have you ever been part of a
religion you always have that that
mindset of we are the good guys we're
not going to be wiped out because our
books say we won't be wiped out
this was Obi Wan's entire life and then
the Jedi his entire order his friends
were wiped out Hartley because of his
friend and apprentice who also killed a
bunch of children and then they rose an
empire and took over the galaxy obi-wan
is tearing that on his shoulders he
feels like that's his fault he's got to
feel like his religion is a lie he is
going to be in a very dark spot in this
movie should be anyway I wanted to be on
Tatooine with this rekt men think
castaway means I don't know good the bad
the ugly I'm kind of a western angle to
it maybe some douchebags so we're
starting stuff with the town and he's
like I don't need to be a part of it I
don't want to be a part of it he's kind
of provoked to be a part of it he helps
this town out or something but I don't
want a lot of lightsabers I feel like
him even looking at his lightsaber in
his sock drawer would bring up the pain
so maybe you'd see it he just closes the
drawer like no and that's all the link
to the next thing I'm going to address
which is what I don't want I don't want
a sci-fi rum I don't want obi-wan Kenobi
to go out there on some space adventure
I want a deep personal story with
obi-wan
want this movie to be like oh yeah best
script Best Actor Best Picture basically
all the stuff we're probably going to
get glimpses of with Luke and his
seclusion I want illustrated with
everyone I do see potential for obi-wan
to go out there on some sort of space
something it had to go into possibly
Imperial spaces like if they find me I
am toast maybe that's where he learns
the fate of Darth Vader though I'm sure
he knows Darth Vader's out there alive
but does he know he's Bionic I don't
know however you can still get that on
Tatooine just stay on tattooing which
means no merch don't make this a merch
fest ever since Return of the Jedi we've
all kind of accepted the fact that Star
Wars is three things
33% space adventures 33% fanservice 33%
merch machines I just delayed it they
integrated it fine with the force
awakens I felt now they have a new Furby
in the new one and people are kind of
pissy about it but in the world where
you have George Lucas saying these
movies are made for kids I guess they
have to appeal to kids while hopefully
appealing to the adults that grew up on
Star Wars but if you're just going to
take one for the team and really make
one that's not a merch machine it's not
meant for kids make this one for adults
just take a knee and be like you know
what guys okay here is an obi-wan kenobe
movie that your kids will probably be
boarded you can have an obi-wan Kenobi
hot toy sure but generally speaking I
don't want a little sidekick character I
don't want a cartoon character and I
understand merchandise is a big part of
how a movie makes its money back which
brings me to the next thing I would be
so happy if I learned that this obi-wan
Kenobi movie was the cheapest Star Wars
yet if you adjust for inflation I'm sure
it gets a little weird boys don't make
it some 300 million dollar sci-fi fest
you see that fan trailer out there of
Kenobi the standalone obi-wan Kenobi
movie trailer came out a while ago but
you look at that you're like oh yeah
that's totally the tone I want and it
would not be expensive to make and if
you keep the budget reined in if you
make it a personal story you don't need
the merch to make the money back this is
the checklist right there I feel like
that's a pretty reasonable checklist I
feel like they could do it well Disney
do it I don't know
since he's kind of set a pattern at this
point to be like god-like big sci-fi
adventures with side characters and
merch machines and I am down for rolling
with that and a lot of Star Wars movies
any of the core movies I know how it is
I get it but for this one I just I don't
feel like it fits the speculation side
of me does wonder if them announcing an
obi-wan Kenobi standalone movie so close
to the last Jedi's release it's only
four months away now I wonder
then getting ahead of the fact that we
might see an obi-wan Kenobi force ghost
in the last Jedi if we see an obi-wan
Kenobi force ghost in the last Jedi that
would jump the probability of an obi-wan
Kenobi movie happening to like 99% if
they didn't announce it now if obi-wan
Kenobi's forest ghosts is in the last
Jedi I will take it as whoever plays
obi-wan Kenobi in the last Jedi is going
to play him in the overland Kenobi
standalone movie though if it's in
McGregor there you go I'm not saying
obi-wan Kenobi's force ghost is going to
be in the last Jedi I'm just speculation
it's fun alright guys so it's standalone
obi-wan Kenobi movie apparently it's
coming out what do you want to see in it
whatever you want to see whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]